app sheet just released new capabilities
built with generative AI that enable its
users to go from an idea to an app in
minutes all using natural language let's
say you want to create an app that helps
track travel expenses you can start by
describing your process to app sheeet at
a high level app sheet engages with
follow-up questions to understand the
needs of your app once it has the
information it needs app sheet previews
the tables for your app and even offers
sample data to seed the app for testing
app sheet go goes off to build the
starter app and when it's ready you can
launch the app directly try out the app
and make your own changes or
iterations we hope these new
capabilities of app sheet inspire you in
thinking about how you might incorporate
generative AI into the evolution of your
own applications